des champs de lavande à perte de vue
plus habitué à la moisson et à la
récolte d'épis de maïs cet agriculteur
s'est lancé dans le lavandin il y a deux
ans aujourd'hui il en a sur 10 hectares
avec cette nouvelle des cultures il fait
des économies et bat lloris des sols à
moindre potentiel
je vais mettre moins d'eau moins
d'engrais vu le prix de l'engrais
aujourd'hui je vois la moins d'intrants
moins de produits phytosanitaires
on passe beaucoup ménec mécaniquement ou
manuellement donc finalement c'est
j'aurai moins de charges sur cette
parcelle la la lavande sert à la
production d'huiles essentielles que
l'on retrouve dans les parfums une
initiative originale un centre val de
loire puisque la région regorge
d'entreprise de cosmétiques par ailleurs
les membres de la coopérative
fournissent une partie de leur récolte
aux apiculteurs le risque de se lancer
dans cette nouvelle culture était donc
mesuré
on trouve les clients et on propose aux
agriculteurs de produire et notre rôle
c'est être sécurisés sur toute la durée
de la production du lavandin parce que
c'est ce qu'on appelle une plante
pérenne qui va rester pendant sept ans
donc on a assuré les débouchés de
l'huile de lavande à à l'agriculteur
pendant sept ans d'ici deux ans 500
hectares de lavandin verront le jour
dans un rayon de 30 km ils seront
plantés autour d'une future distillerie
qui sera construite à orgères en beauce
début des travaux prévu en janvier